vendredi matin wall d'anjou dans l'est
de montréal
on croise des dizaines d'années venus
faire leurs emplettes ou simplement se
désennuyer comme un parfait 30 et il ya
peu de temps donc de rien j'ai pour toi
que je fais mes commissions tout va-t-il
trop préoccupés depuis plusieurs jours
les gestionnaires du centre commercial
ont mis en place des mesures pour
limiter les rassemblements aucune
tableau qu'une chose
aucune banque on a tout enlevé on a
aussi demandé le restaurant de faire
seulement dtk heures d'ouverture
réduites décontamination plus fréquentes
on ne lésine sur aucun moyen pour
protéger la clientèle mais l'idéal
serait quand même que les personnes
vulnérables restent à la maison le plus
apte mais nous empêche de vivre un peu
c'est une morale qui va tomber
enjoy ne tranchait pas bon pour ma
voiture français une gaillette travaille
avec des aînés au quotidien elle
comprend bien le défi que ça pose pour
eux ils veulent être utiles livre ils
veulent bouger y est et rester chez soi
c'est assez pénible
l'enjeu est donc de les garder occupés
et de les valoriser
on a de la laine on a des tissus allard
au volant ce défi à nos bénévoles pour
créer des choses justes les occupés
qu'ils sont utiles puis qu'ils sentent
appréciés
mais comment faire passer le message
auprès des plus réfractaires tap and
when you empêché de sauter parce que
sinon monnier folle - de la maison là
les autorités font maintenant appel à
une autre génération d'influencé pour
atteindre ce public
bonsoir et bienvenue chez moi j'ai pris
le temps d un message pour vous apporter
un peu de réconfort
il faut rappeler à tous que la
distanciation nécessaire est physique
mais cette crise est peut-être
l'occasion d'explorer de nouvelles
façons de garder le contact et de
développer notre solidarité ici julie
aimant radio canada montréal